they take me for idiot
they take me the idea
[Music]
we are live live live
boys boys
[Applause]
[Music]
selector
[Music]
yeah man what an introduction thank you
for that guys we really appreciate you
um being here with us on this fine
Monday afternoon slash morning
you sir now
you already know what it is we love to
do the introductions for your boys today
we're feeling super grateful feeling
super hot because it's warm and
I don't even know what else we're just
blessed we're just blessed it's blessed
because you guys have blessed us so
thank you
I am blessed
I am blessed
every day of my life I am blessed when I
wake up in the morning and I lay my head
to rest every day of my life I am
blessed so maybe link up straight
fun
my my football was slippy bro in the
dance with a linger my tippy toes were
slipping boy bro nalinga I've said it to
you bad on the Pod before time ago
Justin Timberlake had the white version
of nalinga and um
in my love you know
it's sweet to me that I know what you're
talking about
that's funny that's the white nalinga oh
wow hilarious bro Jamaica is so lazy
with their song names not linga as in no
lingering
[Laughter]
around here
come off the road come off the streets
so this I think it's the sweeper motion
I'm off the street yeah no lingering
here wow
creep Gully creep
pondy River pondy Bank
[Music]
as in the Bank of grass on the side of a
riverbed
yeah that's I don't know where their
heads were at when that when that title
was brought to the table Yeah Yeah
really bounce
anyway guys girls you already know what
to do I'm tired of standing but I'm
gonna say it one more time for the
people in the back who refuse to listen
that's you man I'm gonna hold my hand
like a [ __ ] politician you refuse to
listen so what we need you to do is
pause the episode right now Scurry your
little legs oh no I'm gonna be really
patronizing patronizing Jay that's all
that's what happened yeah yeah
patronizing James is on right let me get
into character
cool guys
girls here's what I need you to do okay
pause the [ __ ] video right [ __ ]
now take your stupid little legs those
little miniature little nuggets yeah
take your little [ __ ] Nuggets head
copy on Uber yeah do you know what
keyboard works yeah yeah keyboard yeah
patreon patreon you have to spell it
probably not
patreon.com forward slash that's the one
that leads this forward not the one that
leans back yeah not a fat joking a
regular joking lean forward the line
that leans forward shits and gigs if you
don't know how to spell it look up just
title of the video look up yeah
patreon.com shits and gigs it's gonna
cost you
guessed it three pound a month 10p a day
run the P to SMG okay that's the slogan
if you don't know it by now shame on you
that's it that's it shame on you if you
don't want more episodes kindly
[ __ ] off
because we're in it for the long haul
guys we want the cult babies yes cult
babies only on this channel if you're
not a cult baby unsubscribe and kindly
piss off
you don't know we don't want no one hit
wonders yeah we need repetitions yeah we
need to re repetitive repetitive viewers
and listeners so if you're if you're in
the cult then get balls deep in the car
and pay the three pounds and get a
limited content yeah all the time yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's a Discord server coming soon on
there there's three years of episodes on
there already there it's cheaper than
chips we've established it's literally
cheaper than a portion of chips
an episode every single Thursday you get
over there so one more time for you
idiots you absolutely
[ __ ] idiot the bleachers Rosie they
can't even see us you didn't even pay
that money yet to sit in the front
[ __ ] row it's for you man yeah
patreon.com falls on shits and gigs get
involved or get out my face bro right
now right now cause I'm living yeah
cause okay oh no no you know why she
pumpkin man I'm getting mad oh I'm
actually getting oh no no no no no I'm
actually getting mad
I'm actually getting mad pricks
just do it just right now on the Nike
tank ASAP anyway if you're watching on
YouTube [ __ ] subscribe like comment
chop sitting in the comments let's make
some breeding grounds obviously you
chirps you [ __ ] meet uh yeah yeah
Banger and him and [ __ ] yeah yeah you
know what it is and then babies they get
indoctrinated into the cult and we
educate them about it there's their
lives and you know how it's energy
Library the school is it's really basic
cult yeah tactics yeah standard yeah
right right
um yeah like they're trying to be false
prophets and you're actually longing it
out yeah so subscribe to the channel and
put the notification Bell on because we
just had a meeting earlier like a board
meeting where we decided we're going to
actually produce so much extra content
for you guys not like you deserve it but
whatever I lie if you're listening
for some reason our apple cup podcast
[ __ ] thing has gone up by like
[ __ ] loads of percent over the last
month and that's like without even
trying so yeah thanks I guess
I guess
[ __ ] it out yeah you're a joke you are a
joke [ __ ] sake you're a joke so leave
a review if you want to leave a review
if you listen on Spotify Apple podcast
[ __ ] audible Amazon music Google
podcast whatever man I don't care just
leave a five-star review or piss off as
well five or nothing literally or
nothing five or nothing
joked him waste
and without any further Ado said he
wants to rant about something so let's
listen to what he has to say yeah right
now that that's out of the way all right
cool sorry guys now we actually do love
you love love now that's out of the way
James like
I just want to compose myself because I
want to I fully articulate wait pause
sorry have you you've never done a rant
on here before I used to do rants all
the time I think I've maybe done one but
I don't really remember where the Run
was but I'm excited let's go
talk to me I just want to uh properly
articulate how I feel about the
situation
so where by the time this episode drops
we'll be three weeks in but we're two
weeks in into the Premier League and man
united are pissing me off
man united are pissing me off I've heard
I've seen
statements I don't know what's going on
I know you don't I don't know you don't
so you're gonna have to bear with me all
right bet because I was in Manchester on
Saturday Man City had a game yeah they
obviously won yeah because I'm I saw
smiles and blue that's all I saw blue
and smiles I was at home yeah with
frowns and red
frowns and red James All right so while
going what's going on
pissing me off I got mandam in my
[ __ ] DMS slaying me on a weekly basis
swear talk to me if I was going on so
pre-season right so I'm gonna give you a
full back story all right bet I say full
last couple months backstory so we
changed our whole system because we had
when olly got a social got sacked we had
a replacement called Ralph ragnik who
was a director of football who has never
coached or managed a team before so he
was like the interim prior to whoever we
were gonna sign who is right now
um
why have I just forgotten his name Eric
tanhargan who used to be I Axis which is
in the Dutch League yeah yeah I Axis
um first team manager first team coach
and he was dominating with ayax oh so
the players he already set up he built
his team to what he wanted it to be yeah
yeah coming to United Now new challenge
obviously we've been having difficulties
we've been six for the past two or three
seasons yeah yeah I mean we've not
wanted the last trophy we won
was 2017
Europa League to my knowledge the last
Premier League we won 17 was 2013. oh
God so it's coming on a decade since
we've won the Premier League yeah yeah
and
the way
our competitors and our peers and our
mates have been bantering us for that
this decade yeah yeah it hasn't been
sitting well with it yeah yeah we're not
doing anything about it as a team do you
know what I mean yeah but you actually
know what I mean yeah I know we're not
doing anything about it as a team yeah
pissing me off I'm not I'm not one to
really
show emotion like that towards them
because
I feel like it's one of those stages
where every team goes through a
shortfall yeah you have height when
you're high yeah and we've been we've
been up yeah oh since I was a year yeah
20 years we've been up yeah stay so yeah
as soon as Fergie left in 2013 yeah
it's long the decline has been rapido
he do I'm not gonna like that yeah I've
been holding it in for a while yeah I've
been holding it in for a while let me
just let you know the managers we've
been here yeah right so after
um after Sir Alex Ferguson God bless his
soul left
we've had David Moyes for not even a
whole season I got sacked yeah it was
gash yeah yeah
um we had Louis van Gaal who took us to
the Europa League final and won US the
Europa League final and got sacked
immediately after we then had
Jose Mourinho prolific manager no I tell
a lie
I tell a lie
um I think
Mourinho got us to the final I think
um
we got to a final of something else with
van Gaal I could be wrong but it's
around that same period anyway yeah we
had Mourinho prolific manager
um he's won many cups you know we've we
thought he could do something with
United and he said till this date one of
his biggest achievements was making man
united the shitty man united come second
in the Premier League with 75 Points
city one with 100 I remember that season
yeah yeah and he said that's one of the
best things one of his best achieves his
whole career he's won nothing we won
nothing that year that shows the level
of what he had to do to get us to Second
yeah he didn't sleep with 70 bro we got
58 last season and we were sixth we've
not smelt second in a minute oh I think
we had second twice in ten raw twice in
ten years we've had a second after
Mourinho he got sacked yeah we had only
going to social prolific Striker for
United yeah he had him from uh we had
him for a year and a half but the thing
is with him when we first got him
I think we got him
like mids yeah because Marina got sacked
during the season and then we had um
finger after the break I think it was
during the like um
period like 1920 I think that period and
we once we got him I think we won like
six games on the bounce and we think
okay and the first game we played we won
five nil I remember fully I can't
remember who he played it could have
been like a Norwich or one of them once
I was like okay maybe this side maybe
they want to play for Molly and it
didn't want to play for Mourinho that's
what all the media was saying I was like
oh we started on a highway with six we
ended the season we were sixth waste of
time
yeah
yeah
then we had an interim we had uh Michael
Carrick for a few days so he managed
maybe three games I think we drew two
and one one something like that and then
we got the Ralph ragnik brother who I
said was the manager he was a director
of football for a completely different
team or whatever then came to us he was
with us for about four months yeah yeah
he realized the amount of surgery that
was needed for Man United oh yeah he
said we need to gut our players like we
need like 10 fresh new players yeah
what's happening in our cult isn't
working yeah and we all agreed but the
thing is the glazers are who own man
united right and they are not letting up
so it's always down to them whether they
say yes or no today they're moving broke
yeah that is not they're not necessarily
moving broke they're just not adhering
to what we need oh you know what I mean
so it's a fan versus owner Battle oh
yeah so it's been happening for a few
years now yeah yeah they think they know
best
there's no bad students there's only bad
teachers
and the maddest thing is because
um the glazes are an american-based
family yeah you know what I mean so it's
even worse that they didn't care about
that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so they probably have some some
subsidiary coming in every other month
to check in on man yeah yeah yeah yeah
but we after that we signed someone else
a director executive director who speaks
to glazes blah blah he's English but
that's besides the point that's besides
the [ __ ] point do you know what I
mean yeah yeah so fast forward now to
this preseason just gone which was just
this summer I just gave you a little
back burner what we've been through yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so pre-season right yeah Eric came in we
had we signed three new players who are
quality players we signed a left-back a
central Defender as well as a midfielder
core key positions we haven't had a
striker yet because martial is back from
um martial is back from loan from I
think it was Sevilla
um and he was doing well we gelled in
preseason because I watched all the
highlights and I watched maybe the last
two or three games because I got mutv I
didn't know yeah yeah TV until I just
got the app
we were doing bits like our first game
was against Liverpool and I was thinking
[ __ ] me yeah [ __ ] me in preseason [ __ ]
yeah
it's got tucked in yeah at the end of
the season we just got tucked in yeah
do you know what I mean
[Applause]
this is all Gonna Be Long like this is
Eric's first game buried yeah Eric's
first Dane yeah man we won't see next
week bro oh
lo and behold we tucked them in four nil
oh okay but first half he was our 18
versus their B team and in pre-season
you could flip the whole team yeah yeah
yeah so second half we swapped we put
our B team they put the A Team on and we
scored an extra goal so it was three nil
the first half yeah but that doesn't
really mean much yeah I mean it's great
Optics it doesn't mean much yeah yeah
and we we pretty much buddied the whole
um pre-season we lost one game against
Atletico Madrid which was one nil which
is really good game which I watched yeah
yeah and we also drew our last game
against another Spanish team called Rayo
viacano which I went to which was a
boring game because it was like a lot of
the young teams might we got to see a
lot of the young players play which I
like yeah which I love to see
fast forward to the first game of the
season home game against Brighton
bearing in mind our second to last game
of the last season was against Brighton
they tucked Us in four nil Brighton did
they tucked Us in for Nils the game
after that was Crystal Palace yeah they
tucked us in one that's embarrassing
yeah fam when I say first half these men
were balling my New York right I said
well Balling on us
we had no Pascal gross he's a midfielder
yeah yeah man buried two goals oh in the
space of nine minutes
I could believe it
I couldn't believe it they were playing
as if yeah Brian were playing as if
Brighton were playing like a division
one team yeah yeah yeah like
championship teams it was perplexing to
me like on a Space Jam thing the
monsters
[Music]
it was one of them yeah no so we we lost
two one not two nil we scored again in
the second half it was too little too
late yeah and it was an own goal it was
a me the owned goal it kind of
haphazardly went in yeah you know but he
claimed it anyway yeah thinking up and
that was around like 60 70 minutes I was
thinking maybe you could do a little
something yeah too little too late
cool we took the first heat like first
week down my peers our peers are winning
yeah doing up teams yeah you're doing up
things asked Chelsea Tottenham winning
winning winning
this weekend or last weekend rolls
around now
we play Brentford away
bear in mind we played Brighton just the
week before yeah yeah so here we think
we've got a solid Squad we're away right
there and boys let's just kick some
balls yeah yeah you know it's getting
loose it's not OT yeah it's not 75 000
man united understandable yeah with a
little 20 000 Ting let's just kick some
ball yeah he's got the names on the
pitch yeah James 35 minutes in for nil
James 45 35 minutes into the first half
these men
I couldn't believe what I was watching
the estimated value of brentford's team
is 55 million the estimated value of our
team was something along the lines of
554 million oh and I couldn't leave yeah
I couldn't believe what I was watching
James it's like the price tags were the
other way yeah if I was the owner if I
was a Glazer I'm on the next plane yeah
I want to explain and I want to see
everyone obviously everyone I want
explanations do you know what I mean
because I'm burning money now the thing
is it's not even just the fact that we
lost phone it was how we lost it bro oh
I swear so this that was all in the
first half yeah first goal was a David
de Haye a mistake yeah
um his name is de Silva he shot the ball
Simple Pickup drop collect yeah it
slipped through his fingers went in the
hey David the world's highest paid
goalkeeper let that literally let that
that's what he eating it's a PE to
actually let that slide I was like
that's and added
insult to that is our number two keeper
it's called Dean Henderson he wanted to
he stayed with us all of last season
because he wanted top spot this season
yeah yeah yeah no for a fact he wasn't
going to get we had a new manager blah
blah blah he dipped to Nottingham Forest
so he's on loan for a year and no no for
us they won their game yesterday he's
just saved it he saved the penalty ah
sure insult to injury do you know what I
mean he's cleaning up two games he's
respected yeah yeah points
foreign
[Music]
from the back literal kick I think it
kick to the Maguire Maguire passed it
back to him then he passed the ball to
Ericsson Erickson wasn't paying a like
he was fumbling counter boom they scored
I was like cool two mistakes
all right we need to yeah yeah wake up
wake the [ __ ] up because you're making
these mistakes anymore it's too nil yeah
it's been 15 minutes yeah yeah yeah but
it's a [ __ ] chill because it's gonna
get dangerous now for Man United Things
Are Gonna Get Dangerous 11 boners on the
field now we're hard as a rock bro yeah
big man new big man united yeah in my
yard I know I'm getting sucked off
tonight that's what I know for a fact
James third goal
what happened so third goal we have a
Defender a new signing called um
Martinez right
so he is five foot nine yeah but he
plays
um Central defense and for Central
defense like you are
pivotal for like
um set pieces and Corners yeah get them
all out because yeah you have to be tall
you have to be like six two plus because
Defenders and Strikers around you are
six two plus so there's a brother called
Ben me who plays for Brentford he's
about six three so Ball's coming down
obviously he's uh Martinez versus Ben
knee Ben me doesn't even need to jump he
just knocks the ball in yeah and my
man's just tell it off what do you
expect there's a mismatched thing
mismatch all over the shot so second
half we swapped him for around for
around yeah that's neither here nor
there the fourth goal I guarantee you is
going to be the goal of the month for
August swear well gone it's not the goal
of the month it's gonna be top three
yeah there was a bang at the other yes
yeah yeah I love football guys yeah bro
I could listen to talk football for
eight I love talking about football I
could tell someone needs to scoop you up
not on a Monday on a different day but
yeah Sky Sports needs to scoop you up
but yeah fourth goal yeah
so we had the ball we were doing a Ticky
tackle like I said play from the
goalkeeper yeah yeah yeah all the way to
Darren we were in there in their gold
area bro we were trying to do tikitaka
before we scored
they I can't remember they took the ball
off they yanked it off him in their goal
space man took one touch looked up saw
Ivan Tony pinging it down the line took
another touch squared the ball to him
immediately
before the ball landed right I haven't
Tony so saw
um what's his name bumo who is he's a
she's a striker for Brentford I can't
remember who he was tossing with he
could have been Martinez again yeah yeah
he looked twice the ball bounced twice
and he first time passed it the pass was
beautiful oh yeah yeah my man
trapped it
put some body around yeah yeah and sold
the hair the hair went one way the ball
went the other I've not seen a counter
like that in a very very long time right
that took all of about six to ten
seconds to happen that counter was a
machine to say that counter was
beautiful
that was it this is first half wrapped
that was first half brother
[ __ ] we didn't we didn't concede in the
second half but yeah neither no that's
no way no I can't get this shameful
Behavior shameful Behavior
I
half a billion on the field and they got
found we've been tucked in six one on
aggregate on two games you scored what
we've not even scored a goal because it
was a long goal
we've not scored a goal because
how Ronaldo played the whole game
and my issue with Ronaldo is the things
I I don't have an issue with yeah yeah
United fan other United fans have an
issue with another because people are
saying
he's um
he gets to
um what's the word I'm looking for he
gets too frustrated on the field and
blah blah blah blah he's the only one in
my age show in passion okay yeah you
know what I mean yeah yeah regardless of
whatever you want to say about Ronaldo
he's 37 going on 38. last season he was
our highest goal scorer so he's got 20
goals well 24 goals 18 in the Premier
League yeah you know what I mean yeah
yeah you man you what are you man doing
he's got Tick Tock dancing on the field
do you know what I mean and you say you
have a problem with me
of course he's going to be stressed yeah
yeah yeah of course he forgets I came
here for no reason literally no reason
he thought he was going to come back and
have a Heyday yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's what everyone
thought that's what we I thought it was
going to be a great thing when Manu
almost got me back into football bro I
mean almost I was like are you joking
that's Madness yeah yeah it's about to
turn up yeah this it's all silly bro he
was slapping his knee out four nil yeah
slapping his mouth what am I doing it
yeah I do not blame him yeah these man
these rates he's gonna he's gonna go to
[ __ ] Abu Dhabi bro and do after this
billion dollar deal or whatever it is
blame him yeah I wouldn't blame him
either but this is so annoying that he
gets a lot of the stick when he's the
one obviously not this season yet
because he had to score a goal but last
season
um he was the one to score the highest
um the most goals but anyway to the
point of why I've got this rant about
United yeah yeah the reason why I'm
ranting like this is because I feel like
slight tangent Arsenal last season I've
another tangent I'll come back to
Arsenal last season Arsenal have a show
called um All or Nothing on Amazon Prime
um I haven't I haven't seen it yeah but
it is just
depending what you're gonna say don't we
just forget it
do not forget
my brother about this the other day
because in manually they've got that um
matches they've got a [ __ ] huge
billboard for this Arsenal show yes yes
disrespectful
in big Manchester United
is [ __ ] huge
is [ __ ] huge okay and um
disrespectful but
I'm saying to my brother we walked past
the billboard yeah and I said do you
know what I'm [ __ ] with Arsenal at
the minute
they signed this deal with prime yeah
intelligent yeah because realistically
speaking who gives a [ __ ] who the drink
for Arsenal is no one yeah but it's the
fact that it's Prime KSI and Logan
Paul's drink 100 M's bro they're
bringing young audiences now Sam fam
you're bringing in young audiences and
then and then they do the smartest thing
possible they take one look whoever's
running their [ __ ] media marketing
team is a [ __ ] genius okay they took
one look who Arsenal or KSI man's no uh
Arsenal okay they've done this Prime
team yeah yeah yeah bet yeah we've got
these young men who are going to be gas
now KSI is going to promote us because
he KSI loves Arsenal he's going to
promote the [ __ ] out of us that's patent
now
who on how else are we going to get fans
let's take one look at how the most
boring [ __ ] sport on the planet has
had a Resurgence in fans drive to
[ __ ] survive
Four Seasons deep and these men can't
get enough of it and now formula one's
had a complete Renaissance
let's do it in fact let's [ __ ] do it
yeah yeah yeah because if you think I'm
not watching this [ __ ] I watch
football in like 10 years yeah yeah I'm
watching this Arsenal thing I am
watching because I love tries to survive
and [ __ ] formula one before that yeah
facts before Joshua [ __ ] fabula one who
gives a [ __ ]
I'm watching this Arsenal show so who's
run whoever they've put in the media
team yeah in the marketing team the head
of marketing for Arsenal needs a raise
because this year alone this year alone
he's partnered a bang bang a bang bang I
couldn't believe it I couldn't believe
it I'm thinking whoever's the director
of marketing for Arsenal is killing it
[ __ ] hell back to you
bro just a slight tangent to that you
know there's there's bare all or
nothing's right it's not just Arsenal oh
shut up then I'll shut up then I'll shut
up then right I didn't know that I I
just saw the awesome I was like raw
genius no so there's there's Arsenal
there's I've seen the Man City one as
well watch this I've seen Arsenal boring
Man City there's Juventus there's Brazil
there's there's loads there's Tottenham
there's quite still All or Nothing is a
brand oh I didn't know that I thought
this Arsenal team was the first one I
was like American um footballer there as
well for all or nothing right whatever
it's called cancel everything I just
said for the last five minutes after the
prime bit Yeah Prime still Yes gas
cancel the rest
back to you if you had so yeah my
tangent with Arsenal is that last season
Arsenal as well I also owned by an
American Family called the cronkies I
think I'm pronouncing like a terrible
name but in it oh my American Family
called the crankies and what what um
Mikhail arteta is doing with Arsenal I
hate to say it but I think it's genius
I'll swear I hate to say it genius
what's he doing so in the last season
and a half he signed so many young
players and he's brought up so many
young players from the academy as well
and he's just offloaded all the older
players so the average they're the
youngest average
um age team in the Premier League okay
going yeah since last season yeah yeah
and I think they're all average between
21 and 24.
okay
um yeah so like I said he um
owned by Americans and they shelled out
they they backed they basically backed
arteta so what do you need we will
supply the funds they spent 156 million
in the transfer window last season they
spent the most of anyone
but first because I've been watching the
obviously I watched the season last
season as well but I watched um
Arsenal wool or nothing literally after
the four nil that we yeah yeah yeah yeah
I didn't I didn't want to know what Eric
tanghard had to say listen to the
commentary I just flipped to the site
yeah because I've got to watch it
regardless but it just made more sense
to watch it then
um they lost their first three games and
it's one of those ones where as a
football fan or a fan of any sport like
if you're supporting your team beginning
of season and you're not capitalizing
over the first two or three games
you're gonna think what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah [ __ ] is going on yeah where the
[ __ ] going to my manager this is [ __ ]
you need to change it immediately yeah
everyone was saying out
and I was thinking as a United fan uh
because we I think we won our first game
last season and I'll be due to second or
something like that I couldn't care less
about how they were doing yeah yeah but
I just paid attention to it because I
love football yeah yeah you know
as the season was going on they started
to gel and they started to make those
changes where one person that changed
their whole season in my opinion is um
Aaron Ramsdell who is for context who
his last two teams that he was in were
both relegated Bolton and he was at
Sheffield yeah Sheffield United
Sheffield United they're in they're in
the Premier League two seasons ago got
demoted got relegated and Arsenal bought
them what bought him as their number one
keeper I was like that's a bold move
you'll see inside of him that none of us
have seen yeah yeah Bert Leno was their
number one keeper but he's injury Pro
and he lets goals in oh so
I think the third or second game of last
season tucked in five nil oh and to make
them to make it worse our Teta was
um Pep's understudy for Man City for two
or three years before he left to be an
honest manager oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so getting tucked in five nil was they
were away they were at the sea ground
but that's nonetheless that that that
burnt him scrap Leno off got in ramsdale
and things started moving things like
moving so he's adopted all these young
players got them to understand his style
of play and throughout like the I would
say like the first
um let's say the the the
what's the word I'm looking for let's
say the season is split up into like
eighths right I say the second and the
third out of the eighth of the Season as
well as the maybe the sixth and the
seventh of the season they were playing
football oh they were winning games oh
okay yeah yeah they had a stretch of
like five games on being had another
stretch of like 10 games not necessarily
one but it could be draw win yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah unbeaten yeah yeah yeah
do you know what I mean yeah ended up
the season fifth they could have been
fourth by one point gang
so it's like so now they're coming yeah
yeah they're coming in hot they're
coming in hot and the season they sign
Gabriel Jesus who left Man City to go to
Arsenal pre-season dominating dominating
they played a game yesterday they won
4-2 Jesus scored two and assisted the
other two goals oh do you know what I
mean yeah now we've got a playmaker on
our hands we've got a play makeup we've
got a key part and we've got the
Midfield pattern oh dear come for us
yeah basically I'll set it is saying
come for us yeah yeah we're ready now
the thing the reason why I actually love
All or Nothing regardless of the team is
the web what you literally see behind
the scenes arteta knows how to speak to
his players okay Bet when he always does
like a pre-match talk an hour before and
literally Mac five minutes before the
match and the way he speaks to them
like the the
repeat of the Arsenal seat obviously
lost five notes so the repeat when
Arsenal at home
they got one of the photographers to
speak to the team the photographer has
been playing uh he's been working for
Arsenal for 20 years so he's seen
Legends cards
he's in um you've seen all of them he's
seen all of them come and go and he said
this team right here you are the next
team I see it damn I see it
so I want you guys to go out there and
[ __ ] show me you know
I love this club I would be I'd need to
punch a stranger fan now gas me the way
these men screamed
they won the game 3-1 came back and the
the dressing room erupted I bet erupted
I [ __ ] bet and I was like
going back to United right all these men
are saying oh Eric tag hugging out he
doesn't know what he's doing blah blah
blah big man he's come from a Dutch
League where he's always pretty much
winning every game where he's won three
seasons on the bounce and they're like
goals for and against ratio was like 172
to 20 something he was comfortable yeah
yeah you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
he signed a five foot nine Cent uh
defensive
um a center-back knowing not knowing
what the Premier League's like you know
so for them to say he needs to go or
whatever is ridiculous yeah it's been
two games out of 38. he's his team
haven't had time to jump let's forget
pre-season that's all well a good way it
doesn't count and it doesn't matter yeah
let's just be honest yeah it's just to
get the players fit again yeah
so
you can't you can't judge the Premier
League on [ __ ] two three four five
games you need a [ __ ] huge run I'm
not saying I want us to lose five games
before we find out yeah find our [ __ ]
feet yeah that's unacceptable
yeah draw me yeah give me something yeah
but
everyone was saying our tests are out
last season look what he did for them
you know and I'm not trying it's
annoying because I hate the fact that
I'm having to compare United with
Arsenal in this specific instance yeah
this is the reality of our situation
right now we are no longer the team we
used to be yeah we're not winning
trophies we're not feared Maguire is is
so timid he's tall but he's timid yeah
and he's our captain yeah you know what
I mean he's not long he's not engulfing
any fire into anyone you know what I
mean yeah for that yeah it's long it's
so jarring bro and do you know the peak
is thing
when this comes out
today will be because we play next
Monday which will be today yeah I mean
and we play Liverpool at home
and we just got tucked in four Nils
morale is low James
is low yeah yeah what are we gonna do
yeah we have to but the only saving
grace yeah that people might find this
comment weird because
anyway well I give a [ __ ] the only
saving grace I feel like we have is
martial okay you heard it here first
because
Marsha wasn't doing that great before he
went on loan to Sevilla and we had
alternate Strikers we had alternative
Strikers at the time so he dipped out
he's also a bit injury prone as well
when he came back he was firing in
pre-season you could tell like he missed
working with the boys we used to work
with you know and it it just looks like
okay we are
we look a lot more polished yeah yeah
yeah but he got injured
I think the week before the season
started so he was definitely going to
miss the first two games I.E Brighton
and Brentford and he was skeptical for
the Liverpool game but I just read a
tweet I think the other day saying he's
back into training now so by Monday
hopefully he should be ready if not it's
going to be the game after yeah yeah but
I see it as he is literally our only
Grace to even finding something because
if we just need to score up we've not
scored a goal James man united have not
scored a goal in two games yeah yeah
I'm sorry bro that's my run over Jesus
that was a serious rant bro yeah bro
that was like 30 minutes I haven't
spoken about football a while I liked it
I enjoyed it I missed football oh I bet
I missed I bet bro I loved that someone
needs to scoop you I'm telling you I've
missed it I love football games yeah oh
I can hear it I can [ __ ] hear it bro
um but yeah back to our regular Regular
Show guys
um
thank [ __ ] I put chapters in yeah
speaking of little rant from me
some man ignore chapters do you know how
long it takes me to add chapters to
these episodes It's effort for me it's
effort for me to do it and some people
will be like bro
oh when they're gonna move on from this
click on this chapter click the next
step so it says it right there
that's hilarious anyway that's my run
over 10 second round
um
I saw a thread yeah on Shade Bar the
other day which had me howling all right
bet I love I love it when you find [ __ ]
that I've not seen oh bro I've not even
thought to put on our show fam cool so
this was a tweet that they posted and
the comments were popping off okay women
love to be scorned they see they pretend
like they don't like it but they
secretly love it okay right so the tweet
from sombrer was
since women are known for stealing men's
hoodies did you see this since women are
known for silly men's hoodies is there
something men are known for taking from
a woman's home
fam the responses were disgraceful bro I
remember right the comments I literally
just took like five or six disgraceful
right
so is it for context is there something
men are known from taken from women
first thing I saw they take me for
granted
[Laughter]
they take me for granted the next one
they
they take my kids Capri Suns
I saw that I asked for a wholesome knot
yeah I need juice I need juice I need
glucose
yeah
I'm holding something I need a sugar
high and I need to dip
they take my dignity bro
this one's sweetie me the good charger
they took my credit score
just burning credit cards
burning credit cards oh wow wow catalogs
for days wow I took my credit score fam
the next one they take the piss facts
literally facts they take the [ __ ]
piss they took my youth fam they took my
youth from me they took it all from me
the last one firm they take me for idiot
they take me the idea
laughs
hilarious bro the women of this world
are so [ __ ] funny
it's unbearable I read one that said
they take my peace of mind yeah I read
that too [ __ ] you they take my peace of
mind and my trust
bro it's the funny that was I read it I
was like that's so [ __ ] hilarious bro
it's so jokes Oh my days I knew as soon
as I saw that tweet I knew the comments
were gonna be popping fire fire women
hate men they do but if they just let
them into their homes like vampires they
just invite them in and then just get
facts
they took the good charger oh that that
that's understandable yeah that I can't
stand for no you could ever take my good
charger I can't stand and leave me for
the freighting No No that's my man
that's not acceptable yeah run it back
you can't do that you literally take a
piece of mind but not a charger yeah
yeah yeah yeah take her youth leave her
charger leave her charger
so hilarious
um you had a trash news as well right
oh before you jump into the distractions
I've got a little bit of a trash new
stroke rant oh hit me ecken Sue needs to
take a day off
Atkins Sue needs to take a day the [ __ ]
off
and
[ __ ] love Island yeah but everyone who
voted for her to win yeah be ashamed of
yourself because she manipulated
everyone she's signing deals she's been
out three days she's signed
multi-million deals and she just
announced a travel show
how long has this been cooking
I'm so Furious about food I'm so lividly
Furious David just seems he's up for the
ride
he's here for the dance on the right she
came out with an agenda a [ __ ]
manipulative agenda only days that's
jokes that's jokes she took everyone in
this country for India
a triple show
how long did that she doesn't have time
to cook in cooking
cooking
her manager would have patterned all of
that bro yeah this has been cooking
since the day she entered the house
cooking I can't afford a PR I can't
fault it either oh poly one million oh
Polly the face of old party one million
dot pound deal
days after she left the Villa she just
won 50 bags that day
50 bags that day and she's got a meal
three she's got a meal a couple days
later
and then I'm hearing a travel show you
I saw that and through my [ __ ] phone
it's like is this [ __ ] serious
travel show
it's been a few days let's let him
marinate bless just believe you actually
love each other and this isn't just a
hoax let's believe it for a second she
doesn't care oh that's too funny she
doesn't care that's too funny we've got
India out here just actually got a blue
tick
doing big money deals
what the rest of you man doing
firm she manipulate the whole game oh
God
she's busy making Million Dollar Deals
you man I do not blueticks tweeting
about blue ticks you should be ashamed
of yourself
where's the money
where the [ __ ] is the money India oh
that's what I want to hear what's that
my name dummy dummy in India
where's the money because you were the
Beloved yeah you were the Beloved black
power couple oh they were and you man
are doing up kiss fresh and blue ticks
Atkins Shoes making deals bro what's
going on
bro I love I'm so angry I love the
person yes
Tommy and ninja need to step your money
up
we're doing blue ticks and dances and
kiss fresh with Henry dances oh let's
make some money the thing is I know they
were they are a very buff couple they
will they're gonna they're gonna get
some modeling something but they're
gonna do something the only the thing is
right because I watched I watched
majority of last season love about it I
didn't watch probably like the first few
weeks
um
so I watched it probably like just maybe
a week before casamo and then everything
else yeah yeah
so I saw little tidbits of ekansu's like
bad behavior bad side million punitive
side yeah yeah towards the rest of the
um Islanders only a little bit but then
I saw
the other side of her or the other side
of both of them because they they are
very much a married couple they argue
they cook they make up they laugh yeah
yeah and what you don't tell these
actual entertainment yeah yeah watching
them too is actual entertainment so from
that period alone I knew they were gonna
win all right I knew that everyone did
everyone loved it yeah yeah they were
automatically draw that I knew they were
going to win
the but that aside every single body
every single couple in that house loved
Damian India bro they all did bro there
was a thing where they had to vote for
their two least favorite least
compatible couples that mean India got
zero folks out of the six everyone else
got four three two one votes they got
none I was thinking gang because where's
the money where's the money I said money
where's the money at
fam literally I'm not even joking
whatever day it was Thursday because I
showed it to you didn't I yeah yeah oh
politics yeah yeah Thursday we're doing
up oh probably one million deal yeah by
Saturday we're doing travel up shows
yeah yeah you know in in the space of a
week less than and then I'm going on
Instagram and shaders talking about how
India's gas station got Bluetick
show me some money balance show me some
money yeah some money money
but then again that's exactly what
happened with um it's actually reversed
him because Amber won the show a few
years ago it was the same year as money
may not Molly May got the PLT thing
Amber to our knowledge this oh that's a
mixed race yeah yeah she didn't get
nothing well I think she got something
that's what I'm talking about these
white men are doing her business deals
these black lot
where's [ __ ] what's his face from
five years ago who basketball Donnie
what's his name
yeah he was the guy yeah he was the
nation loved him bam black white asian
green red blue he loves the new Annie
Joshua where's the money at he just grew
cane Road that's all he did he's doing
up Kane Roman durags where's the money
at these men are doing PLT these men are
doing oh poly
found this white man to clean it up it's
business for them these black lot are
just here
we're just here where's the money at
India dammy where's the money here Opie
where's the money Amber Amber's just
complaining about stuff till now she
just complains about stuff she tweets
and gossips she tweets and gossips she's
on the podcast talking about who's
sliding her DMS and stuff oh yeah I saw
that I saw that Amber where's the money
where where is it [ __ ] denique is
twerking on something
where's the money yeah
[ __ ] where is it when you put in context
like that yeah these white men are doing
up deals they're doing business they're
doing business they're coming out of the
villa and making cash what are we doing
what are we doing
yeah yeah we're twerking we're balling
we're gossiping we're whistle blowing
nah and we're just Tick Tock dancing oh
my god oh my god let's do some deals
guys seriously I'm not even joking
anymore let's do some deals we can make
it happen let's do some deals I like the
energy it needs to happen because I'm
tired of it I'm sick and tired of it
year after year after year
and and I feel like uh Damien India were
like the first the first Power black
couple in um love Island there was one a
few years ago with um
I can't remember his name but I remember
his face and the other chick that owned
was that um
uh the baby shower
I can't remember now but you know what
I'm talking about
yeah you know what I'm talking about
yeah I know you talk about yeah yeah
Priscilla yeah yeah I can't remember the
guy her skin don't make sense it doesn't
it's it's clear like it doesn't have
there's no um
no Paws or blemishes yeah she doesn't
have paws it's just she's glow
it looks like it's made of velvet or
something yes yes yes
it doesn't make sense yeah Priscilla
banging yeah yeah banging yeah so um her
and I can't remember the brother's name
forgive me but they were a look a local
power couple once they left as well I
think they came like third or fourth um
in that season but it didn't really do
much else where's the deals oh could I
be thinking of someone else
maybe I'm thinking of someone else no it
was prison I'm sure anyway long story
short yes let's do up some deals yeah
guys are you melanin man yeah let's do
up some deals because this is becoming a
running Trend and it's embarrassing to
look at
it really is it's honestly embarrassing
yeah yeah yeah yeah let's do some big
money deals big money deals this time
next year the next power black couple
that comes out of love island in the
first week
deals yeah we want to see it no none
this Blue Tick dance in Malarkey yeah
you want to see big boy headlines Blue
Tick needs to be the least of your worry
you should have been Bluetick before you
leave the Villa yeah like yeah he's
doing a million followers before she's
even exited before she even knew she won
she was a 1.5 so what are we doing it
let's capitalize yeah because we all
know love Island can make you a career
yeah and they can soon do that from time
from before she got in there she was
like bet yeah she had that agent doing
due diligence from early behind the
scenes early you man are just caught up
in the love
you just caught up in it stop
[ __ ] stop focus
focus focus because I'm tired of seeing
it
Christ anyway [ __ ] yeah the trash news
[ __ ] that was hilarious I was so
unexpectedly hilarious oh my God right
there was a video by I honestly can't
find the video anymore so I've only got
a picture so drunk driver who crashed
her Mercedes going a hundred miles an
hour in La killed six people is
identified as 37 year old nurse Nicole
Linton she tried to commit suicide over
a man
context
the woman responsible for the tragic
multi-car wreck at the La Brea Slauson
intersection in West LA Thursday has
been identified as well where I just
said 37 year old nurse Lorraine Linton
Linton survived
and has been arrested and amid her
hospitalization on grounds of vehicular
vehicular manslaughter with gross
negligence according to the authorities
she said um she got um she's currently
at Ronald Reagan Medical Center with
moderate injuries
suspected of driving at least 100 miles
an hour the drunk driver plowed into the
busy intersection at 1 40 pm
La Sentinel claims the life of six
people including a pregnant woman
identified by the coroner as Ashley Ryan
23 and her infant son
this woman tried to dumpy herself
because of next man
and duppied off six other men and came
up came out moderate with second-degree
burns that's bro but the mad at the
video
oh no so that's the picture
Jesus I saw it on Twitter fam she sped
onto oncoming traffic I couldn't believe
it Christ almighty because of man
I could bro that's
that is I'm happy she's actually got
arrested because that's stupid that's
[ __ ] regardless of the situation like
kill yourself in peace like I know this
is not something we ever see obviously
ever got to promote whatever but yeah
don't ever put other people's lives in
your hand because of how you feel yeah
bro honestly like obviously we get it
like you're going through literally the
worst possible thing to the point where
you're like I don't want to live anymore
yeah I can literally don't want to live
anymore yeah and so it's hard to kind of
speak logic into that of course but same
way
away from me yeah yeah if you're gonna
do it keep the the Innocence out of it
bro that's awesome of six other people
that's all we asked and she got a couple
Birds she didn't even die and she's just
gonna link up with a therapist and she's
gonna do up jail yes she's yeah she's
gonna have to do it she's gonna have to
and she's now gonna live the rest of her
life in pen like [ __ ] I could have just
gone to therapy or something yeah
literally like I'm over what guy from a
year and I'm over it yeah yeah
oh yeah I've been eating on oh it's it's
that's horrible horrible that's [ __ ]
horrible Jesus Christ sorry I was like
wow wow oh wow that took a sharp time
today wow we right I've gone to my the
[ __ ] gang okay cool
so this is a a little bit of a long one
but not really
so
hi guys I just want the third party
opinion and not from someone who's
connected to the situation basically
I've been with my partner for nine years
we've got two kids together and we're
never getting married he's made that
clear
basically I don't even like him anymore
oh wow bro I'm not sure if I even love
him I feel we've wasted a lot of time
over the last few years and he refuses
to accept this and move out
our relationship can either be okay or
very toxic
we never do anything together we've
never been on holiday together bro we've
been out a maximum of four times
together in the nine years we've been
out a maximum of four times for food
wow I do all these things with the kids
on my own he's never interested or wants
to come along but he refuses to leave I
kick him out and he comes back to see
the kids and just lurks around
okay I'm thinking about doing a midnight
flick just packing me and the kids up
and leaving and not even telling him
just cut enough cutting off all contact
he isn't interested in doing any family
stuff the thing that makes me feel bad
is the kids are used to seeing him every
day and him vice versa
if I was to leave would I be an [ __ ]
if I did tell him it would just turn
into a massive drama
which I've never understood because I'm
95 sure he doesn't even like us being
around him anyway it's very confusing
I'm tired of wasting my time and his I
do find him attractive and he does
provide financially but that's it there
is no more layers to our relationship he
says he loves me and the kids but I
think it's quite obvious he isn't
invested in the family what do you think
so recap
they've been together
um nine years they use they've got two
kids together
they don't sleep together they don't go
out together he has no interest in her
she has no interest in him at this point
their relationship at any one point
their relationship is either just okay
or extremely toxic she's kicked him out
multiple times and all he does is come
over to see the kids and just doesn't
leave he comes back over to see the
yeah very smart he's a piece of [ __ ] boy
he comes over to see his children I said
I need to see my [ __ ] kids I need to
they're my kids I need my children and
he just doesn't leave he brings his bag
with him and puts it down and sits the
[ __ ] down
um and then so she's thinking right I've
tried everything to get this guy out my
house yeah it's not working
obviously they're married she probably
legally can't get rid of him so the only
thing she can think to do now is based
on the fact that he shows very little
interest in her very little interest
into the kids that he keeps wanting to
see yeah she wants to pack the kids up
in the middle of the night and [ __ ]
run away cut off all contact which means
the kids are never going to see their
dad again yeah most likely most likely
um which she thinks is the only way that
she's ever gonna be able to move on from
this and this horrible relationship but
her only concern is the kids love their
dad they live with their dad and the dad
needs his kids
so she would she feels like potentially
I'm maybe putting words in her mouth she
probably feels like it's a very selfish
decision that mainly benefits her more
than anyone else
so what should she do would she be an
[ __ ] if she did if she wants to say
if I just pack up my [ __ ] in the middle
of the night and take the kids and run
am I the [ __ ]
not even to even talk about the latter
or like the bottom half of what she just
said I think she's the [ __ ] for
knowing that they've only been on four
dates in nine years like regardless of
when these four dates were spread out in
these nine years you know for a fact
he's not taking you out for a couple
months after the first you what are you
doing you know what I mean yeah yeah
yeah two YouTubes together yeah yeah
they're married you got married two
youths together before you were even
married what was he doing like how what
was floating your boat about this yeah
you know what I mean yeah it's a weird
one I need obviously we're not going to
get the context or the background of
that but I just don't understand how
you can
keep yourself in that situation
over such a long period of time let
alone having another Ute with the
brother you know so that's where my
heads are initially that's why I was
like you [ __ ] up from the jump yeah
let alone from what's Happening Now
secondly
if you dare leave the yard at the middle
of the night without the father knowing
I promise you someone is dying I promise
you yeah because he will find you yeah
yeah yeah yeah this he sounds he sounds
like he doesn't care oh he sounds like a
bum he will find you yeah yeah because
he wants his YouTube yeah yeah
regardless of you he's gonna want his
use in his life so I feel like that's
not a decision you want to make yeah you
probably don't wanna I can feel I can
tell that you feel very boxed in yeah of
course and you don't know what to do
but the only thing I can suggest is you
need to come with some intervention take
yeah
and just I don't know get get your
sister around get your Bridges round get
his mum round
[Music]
get some people around
and just have an open plain discussion
where he has nowhere to hide but like
I've taken these links because I'm on
the verge of packing all the kids and
their [ __ ] and dipping and you'll never
see us again so what we need we need you
to leave bro because this relationship
is horrible and I don't want to be here
and I've kicked you out multiple times
and you worm your way back in and you
use the kids to do that now what I'm
saying in this very public format so
everyone can hear me
I am done bro you need to leave or I
need to leave I don't give a [ __ ] who
leaves but the kids are coming with me
yeah and wherever I'm at the kids are
staying yeah you need to leave bro like
today and one of these man's gonna take
you in until you can find your own place
but you need to be gone today yeah
because this this can't patent anymore
yeah that's I feel like that's a great
idea but it's definitely a great a great
idea to do because it puts them in a
position where it's like [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
in front of everyone else yeah he would
knowing I don't know him by knowing him
he will storm the [ __ ] out oh one
million he'll play like he's never been
kicked out before like big man if you
just want me hit him you think I want to
be here you think I want to be one or
win it I'll go I'll go I'll [ __ ] go
he's gonna get a car and cry
he's going to get in the car and cry
about like baby please please don't do
this please I forgive you just to let
you know I forgive you for what you just
did to me please let me back
forgive you forgive you don't you dare
change the locks don't you dare change
the locks I'm not driving anywhere I'm
gonna sit out here in my car till you
let me back
fam yeah it needs to be done in a very
public setting yeah so he has nowhere to
hide Andrew for you to be like
guys everyone in this room listening if
this [ __ ] lives here again just numbers
against my will yeah yeah I'm letting
you all know now if you find him in this
yard again regardless what he tells you
is against my will come and get him come
and [ __ ] get him come and get me come
and get me come and find me yes sort it
out yeah [ __ ] it that's what needs to
happen that's a that's very sticky man
like it's it's obviously very very tough
when you have kids involved and stuff
obviously I I have no idea but like I
can imagine it's going to be very very
tough when you have kids involved
especially when it's that current
situation where you're not even jetting
with the the baby dad or the baby one
whichever scenario you're in you know is
that's [ __ ] tough man he people use
kiss to manipulate that and that's so
unfair on who whichever party you're
whichever side you're on is so unfair
it's never going to be fair on the kids
the kids don't know any better they just
see it as mum and dad and it's like
that's that's just life but
yeah that's that's tough
um hopefully do what James said try and
do a little intervention with his family
your family so there's Witnesses you
know he needs to understand because
clearly whatever you're saying to him
he's taking you from mug because he's
not registering anything yeah he don't
write you as a person he doesn't rate
you and it's not registered so if you
say it in a public setting like James
said he's going to realize he's gonna
he's gonna see the reaction on everyone
else's faces like all right I am a piece
of [ __ ] yeah yeah I really need to
change my ways yeah yeah and maybe he
might do something about it but until
then
yeah don't you don't you dare take the
kids in the middle of the night don't
yeah
and well that causes walls and you'll
have no one to fall back on no one
because because all of the mistakes fam
you've made the mistake yeah yeah yeah
yeah like it doesn't matter what he's
done in the past as soon as you do
something like that that's what that's
when the laws your friends will turn
against you yeah yeah the feds are on
you yeah this is a kidnapping team his
mum's on you his family's on you
everyone's on you bro like you'll never
have a leg to stand on again if you do
something like that he's taking you to
court and he's suing for uh for full
custody and then you're used to with a
shitty dad that they never want to be
with you're [ __ ] yeah don't don't you
dead don't you dare do that bro your own
benefit and your kids are benefiting
don't do it um but hopefully that helps
and finally we I've been promised that
this is a funny one I've had a great
episode
Pam after I forgot we even had to answer
your questions that's how much I've
enjoyed this episode I forgot I was even
thinking I was literally just about to
be like guys uh thanks for the episode
right I'm ready so what is the question
of the day
the question of the day this week guys
is what's the worst insult you've ever
received
and as the slogan says guys the
responses were
juicy I'm gonna do what I'd normally do
and just real you're just gonna bang
them out off all right say less I'm just
gonna reel them off I'm ready I'm ready
I'm ready I'm ready ready
I was once called underdeveloped by my
bitter ex assuming because of my b cup
tatas
underdeveloped I looked like my mother
and father are the same person
your
tongue is so big and dry it feels like a
dog is eating me out wow your ADHD was
cute but can you stop it now
I hope both sides of your pillow are
warm tonight
[Laughter]
I'm 5 10 I'm a 5 10 female and my
therapist said yeah I'd hate to be your
height too
toys I look like a before picture no
nah got asked if I had a boyfriend when
I said no he said make sense
[ __ ] your teeth are so big I bet you cut
it when you give head
a guy a guy on Tinder matched with me he
said I look like Soul Campbell and
blocked me
you're so cute
I fake tanned my legs my mother-in-law
said I had a nice color what only to
tell her son that I actually looked
dirty
yeah your mum gets shared around the
group chat with 27 men in there and your
dad's the admin yeah
the best part of you ran down your
mother's legs
no
no on a glazed crispy
wow
I saw that my jaw dropped
the best part of you ran down your
mother's legs that's impossible that's
important
that's impossible to hear insult to my
surname to the whole family yeah yeah
[ __ ] he took us all out with that
wow that was a strike yeah that was a
strike
you're so flat your nipple rings are
like Staples on a piece of paper
I'm four foot eleven and he said you're
not thick you're just compressed
you'd be pretty if you did your makeup
like me uh what
showed my mum a picture of showed my mum
a before and after picture after four
months in the gym and she said you're
just standing further away from the
mirror no you look like a dirty piece of
chicken
a homeless man said I'd be lucky to
marry him because I can't do any better
yo someone said you could land a
helicopter on my forehead no fam
a kid poked me in the belly and said
Wibble wobble
no no no no no no no no no no I'd wanna
love them no no no I'm rocking that kid
that might
that my mom died because she couldn't
stand being around me
no Bro you've had so many kids I can see
straight to your heart through your
vagina
huh my eyebrows have no curve
[Laughter]
I'd rather slice off my eyeballs and
stare at the Sun than hang out with you
Jesus Christ I realized my husband had
never called me beautiful when I saw it
written on the back of one of his ex's
photos oh allow it low it that household
would have been different more written
that yard would have been different that
day [ __ ]
my ghost
said she likes watching my belly move
back and forth during missionary no no
bro I uh
[ __ ] that's embarrassing
oh it's impossibly embarrassed this is
the biggest oxymoron go on rejected a
man in the office and he called me a
frigid [ __ ]
I told a girl her tits look look like
two paracetamols on an ironing board
did they say did he say he's that he
said that he said that to a chick and
he's proud of such two paracetamols on
an ironing board
a scale far a scale for you [ __ ] a
stranger saw a donut on my desk and said
are you sure you should be eating this
[Music]
foreign
she was never yours it was just your
turn
wow I told my deadbeat baby daddy he has
the hairline of his dad his dad has
alopecia
[ __ ] that I love you but I don't want
any more kids with a white woman oh
[Laughter]
Jesus fam if you weren't so tall you'd
be alone
[ __ ] off
my students said my outfit was my
students said my outfit was a bold
choice
they're 14 and I've never worn that
outfit again
and that's a bold choice choice name
kids kids can be so cruel if you had oh
so
what's the word I'm looking for oh so ah
the word was in my head is just gone
like unfiltered not even unfiltered
they're so
yeah yeah let's just go with unfiltered
they are [ __ ] on their unfiltered
they're original and they're scathing
they they tell the truth and they don't
care about the repercussions they don't
care about the repercussions and they
prey on your largest insecurity largest
they don't know how they know but they
know family I read the I read the
pointed out of the stomach and said
Wibble wobble oh my God believe why I
can't fam kids are vile the things
Wibble wobble I don't think you
understand what I would do to me Wibble
wobble I don't think because because
they're a kid it's not lies it's not
they tell the truth they only know the
truth Wibble wobble
on an alliteration thing and they just
walked off and got on with their day
you fat [ __ ] basically you [ __ ] fat
[ __ ] basically and then just held his
mum's hand and walked off
last but not least
for someone with no tonsils you can't
deep throat for [ __ ] oh [ __ ] off
that's brutal
ah fam worst insults worst insults
that's Savage that missionary thing I
like watching your belly go back and
forth
why are you saying this to me why are
you saying this to me this is neither
not the moment this is neither the
moment or the moment you think it was
yeah what did you want my response to be
thank you baby let's keep going yeah no
I love being a [ __ ] slob
I'm so happy you love me being a fat
[ __ ] bro I love watching your fat
stomach go up and down when you [ __ ] me
oh Jesus I would never speak to her
again and I'm training from tomorrow for
James the amount of cardio I'll do I
don't think my legs will cope fam and I
will pray for her to tell me oh I liked
you but better before [ __ ] off [ __ ] you
and your mom
[ __ ] you you're the reason I'm like this
facts bro oh mate oh goodness me but
guys girls cool man that was a fantastic
episode I hope you that was a lot of fun
I laughed as much as we did that was a
lot of fun yeah we had Ransom we had
jokes there was a lot of rants in there
yeah
um but guys as always love you like a
fat kid loves cake and [ __ ] you know my
style I say anything to make you smile
and [ __ ]
um have a good week see you on Thursday
let's see
[Music]
laughs